okay there they are he is the host of
the beat with our remover in Chief legal
correspondent on MSNBC Ari melber is
over here
and she's a lawyer the senior editor for
the dispatch and an ABC News political
analyst Sarah isgar is back with us hey
okay so we have uh
two media Pros here so let's talk about
the big news media news story Fox News
we can talk about them can't we um this
I thought was pretty interesting and if
you haven't been following this Dominion
those are the people who count the votes
right okay so Fox News when Trump was
ranting about how he lost the election
accused uh Dominion of rigging the vote
so they sued Fox News which they should
and it's in court so when you're in
court then you get to see things so now
we saw the texts
from different Fox news correspondents
to each other and I mean
among the
stories about they knew it all along but
they still did it this is what this was
is right up there with cigarettes
opioids Wars they knew we couldn't win
um here's Tucker Carlson
he's writing I don't know who he's
texting to but it's a tweet after uh I
mean somebody tweeted from Fox News a
fact check
Tucker's response was please get her
fired seriously what the
it needs to stop immediately like
tonight it's measurably hurting the
company the stock price is down
Smoking Gun much
so how do they spend this I guess is my
quest how did they uh the talkers Tucker
was on this uh Sean Hannity Laura Ingram
how how do they spend this
just wants to be like let them bury
themselves I don't have to say it
I should disclose my husband is a lawyer
involved in the case
look
that we don't like to talk about in the
media these media organizations are
private corporations their business
model for a lot of them has changed a
lot in the digital era so that yeah
they're very concerned about for
instance their subscribers in a way that
it used to be about ad revenue for
instance and we've seen that shift away
from ad Revenue where you're trying to
get you know I don't know GM to have
their car on your show to now it's all
about the individual subscribers and
that's why you see this fracturing of
news organizations catering to
ideological niches within the ecosystem
I don't think it's been very good I'll
say respectfully that's like a
structural analysis of stuff in media
but I think this story is about the
people at Fox lying they know they're
lying they're busted only because they
got Dragon to court as you said Bill and
so it's actually really important
because it shows that yeah the first
amendment should protect all kinds of
ideas opinions everything it doesn't
protect a right to lie us into an
Insurrection and that's what they're in
trouble
yeah
this is
this is a this is a let's not make false
equivalencies this is a level Above This
is just different I mean this is you're
getting I mean the tweet I love it he
also gives the motive the stock price is
going down
and so and Sean Hannity in a deposition
admitted he never believed any of
Trump's lies for a second so it's very
different than just saying oh is this
tailored or are you overly concerned
about an audience a live audience an
audience on television no they were in
on it and for everyone afterward who
said oh well Trump believes his lies oh
Tucker believes his lies not this one
but there are there's many ways to lie
or maybe not lie but leave an audience
with a false impression and part of it
is to leave out information so I think
what you're saying and I would concur
and I think you said a minute ago pretty
much the same thing that the structural
problem with media is that they tell the
viewers what they want to hear because
you guys are getting ratings sometimes
by the minute and you don't want those
people to turn the dial